hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
titled development of an extraction-free
saliva-based workflow
for sars co-v2 detection with the
biomark hd platform
i am alexis corrales of labyrinths and
i'll be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
sponsored by fluidim
now let's get started before we begin i
would like to remind everyone that this
event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you would like during the
presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we will answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation click on the ask a
question box
located on the far left of your screen
i now present today's speakers dr david
king
vice president of r d genomics and
product management at fluidim
and professor richard head director of
the genome technology access center
at the mcdonald genome institute at
washington university school of medicine
in st
louis for a complete biography on dr
king and professor head
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen
dr king you may now begin your
presentation
hello my name is david king i'm vice
president of
r d for genomics at fluoride and i'd
like to talk to you today
about the advanta dx sars curvy 2 rtpcr
essay that we've recently introduced
in thinking about the critical needs for
molecular diagnostic testing for curved
19
there are four essential important
ingredients that are essential
scalable sample throughput rapid
turnaround time
assay capacity and coverage and
operating efficiency
and those are all achieved without with
the product i just
described we'll describe in a minute
fluidized satisfies the critical needs
by that i've outlined by
enabling throughput using modular
systems that can scale to thousands of
samples per day
we can eliminate the supply chain issues
and the
supply rapid turnaround time using
a new extraction-free method that
shortens and simplifies our overall
workflow
and or not of when you look at operation
operating efficiency
we've max we can maximize your
laboratory budget by minimizing reagent
consumption
using our key microfluidic technologies
implemented in devices that we uh sell
that automate reaction assemblies at the
nanoliter scale
so let me focus on advanta dx south
korea 2
real-time pcr essay
the assay is accurate efficient uses
non-invasive or uses of non-invasive
sample type saliva to meet the global
need for
rapid diagnostic testing for south korea
to infection
again as i mentioned there's no need for
viral rna extraction without
with our kit it's extraction free
it achieves 192 analyzes 192 samples and
controls every
35 minutes at maximum throughput
and it's scalable we with one of our
installations
you can scale up to six thousand samples
uh and controls per instrument or per
installation per day
and the workflow at the at the bottom of
the slide is very simple one collects a
saliva there's a simple sample prep step
a processing on our juno and
biomark systems to generate the up to
6000 samples a day
let me talk about our regulation
notification we
uh fluidize files for emergency use
authorization
with the fda the test is being validated
um
by fluoride and we have partnered with
washu
on the clinical clinical work for this
application i'm going to talk briefly
about uh our genetics uh genomics and
microfluidic systems uh as a whole so
fluidity has been around for about 20
years and we have developed
a deep technology and uh
many pla put in the marketplace many
products
based on integrated fluidic circuits or
ifcs
these are basically microscopic chips so
in the upper right hand corner
is a view of one of our microfluidic
chips it comprises
an area a region clear region on the
outside of this uh microphonic ship
where one pipettes
samples and essays and the black part in
the center
is the business part where we combine
and process
all the samples and assays
simultaneously so we can
process up to 10 000 sample 10 000
reactions all simultaneously
equivalent to let's say 196 well plates
or 96 964 plates
um all the nanolater scale these
microfluidic chips are processed on our
platforms the juno
ngs library prep platform and the
biomark hd
pcr qpcr digital pcr platform
that utilizes canned reagents or
kits that we supply and then we also
supply
design services to optimize uh
particular
essays for your own use
um the biomark hd is a
robust high throughput pcr based
platform um
it really again it enables uh the
operation of
our uh ifcs uh microsoft ships
and it's been on the market for quite
some time so it's a very reliable
um reliable robust platform
we've enabled multiple applications on
this simple
architect within the simple architecture
from gene expression genotyping
sample id uh copy number variation
digital pcr
now um our first diagnostic product
viral
rna detection our microfluidic chip
integrated fluidic circuit as i
mentioned this is a closer up view
you can see where the essays and samples
are prepared into the architecture this
is basically the same size
as a 384 well plate the world positions
are consistent with standard sbs
formats so that they're easy to use by
hand or by
automated robotic systems and the the
the
microfluidic chipper integrated is
integrated solidic circuit that we've
implemented for the advanta dx
52 sa can take up 100
up to 192 samples at once
i wanted to highlight that this work was
uh our work with
science kb2 was in very close
collaboration with washington university
school of medicine
we um both co-developed the essay
um we both performed independent
analytical validations
and watch you perform the clinical
validation
uh i believe washington university
intends to use this
and implement this test to increase
testing capacity
in not only the university environment
but also at the greatest
louis area just a
very quick snippet of some of the data
that we provided
to the fda here we'll be showing a table
of data where we're
showing that a limited detection for
this particular assay is down to 6.25
viral copies per microliter of sample
we've also this is a summary i think
jeff's going to talk i think rich is
going to talk about it in a minute
um for our product performance and
clinical validation where we have 100
concordance with blinded nasal
pharyngeal swabs
um it's very important to show that
there were no false positives or no
those negatives in this clinical data
set
as i mentioned we've worked very closely
with jeff jeff milbrand and rich head
who will hear from in just a moment
at washu um at washu and it gives me
uh great pleasure to now turn the uh
presentation over to richard head who's
professor of genetics and
pathology and immunology
and the director of the genome
technology access center at the mcdonald
genome institute at washu school of
medicine
uh he's going to talk about the
development of extraction free and
extraction-free throttle-based workflow
for sales kv-2 with the biomarker hd
platform
so rich over to you
so first i'd like to take just a moment
to thank david king and fluidigm for the
opportunity to speak today
and to share some interesting results
from the recent collaboration that david
just
described so as mentioned i am the
director of a facility called gtac at
mgi
which is the genomics division of the
mcdonald genome institute here at washu
in st louis
our lab consists of about a hundred
scientists technicians and support staff
we run tens of thousands of samples per
year we have both research and clinical
cap clia regulated laboratories and
as as david kind of gave you a bit of a
a preview
we've had an interesting journey and i'm
going to go a little bit more into the
detail
uh of some of this journey and in terms
of how we got to where we are today with
the development of this assay
so uh in the late january early february
time
frame my lab had initially come decided
that we were not going to engage in
covet-related test development for a
number of different reasons
however around march we really
reevaluated that position
based on some of the issues that we were
seeing associated with assays that were
in use both here and and really around
the world and
began investigating a number of
different assay formats that
could potentially circumvent some of
these key issues that a lot of
laboratories were seeing
for example you know np swabs are very
uncomfortable
for the subject that's having the sample
taken
there are supply chain issues that have
been reported numerous times
particularly with rna extraction kits
and for the types of massive scale
screening that really
need to be going on uh during this
pandemic cost is also an issue
so we we we really decided at that point
that we would engage
in the process and i'm going to discuss
basically a little bit of that path
and how we ended up where we are
so based on that starting premise
um we first established a set of goals
that we sought to achieve
in in the process of of getting to an
assay that we thought could
uh address the number of these issues so
first
we were interested in something that
would allow for serial testing
meaning repeated tests with something
other than np swabs as we know those are
very uncomfortable
self-collection was something that we
thought would be advantageous because
we obviously would like to reduce the
risk to healthcare workers
we were cognizant of supply chain issues
large-scale testing combined with
impacted production from the pandemic
has led to a number of supply chain
issues
the throughput sensitivity and
specificity were all
issues that were key in our mind that
this had to be very sensitive very
specific
and we really wanted something that was
very high throughput to drive the
usefulness as well as our trust in the
assay
and eventually and also finally low cost
i mean
economic factors have to be considered
especially within academic institutions
like ours when we're
doing very large scale particularly
repeated large-scale
testing so we made a few decisions
based on those goals right out of the
gate first we decided we were going to
choose
pursue a saliva based test as i
mentioned this is something we thought
would be much more comfortable
for serial testing and therefore likely
lead to better compliance
we also thought it was much better
suited for self-collection
we also then chose to pursue an
extraction-free route
so rna extraction kits have been subject
to supply into chain issues as i've
mentioned a couple times
and so we really thought an assay if we
were going to work in this space we
really wanted to try to get to something
that was going to be
extraction free which also helps reduce
costs and processing time and
uh our eventual goal was to get to
something that could be used for
workplace screening now the assay that
i'm going to describe today
is being reviewed by the
fda as a patient testing
assay but it is definitely our goal to
eventually get to workplace screening
with this assay
so our first attempt uh was not actually
with rtpcr
our first attempt was with rt lamp uh
if you're not familiar with rt lamp this
is the reverse transcription loop
mediated isothermal amplification
which is a bit of a mouthful which is
why everybody calls it rt lamp
this has been around for quite some time
and it has been
used quite often as
a poc test where central testing
facilities are not available
for a number of different reasons it
requires very little lab infrastructure
um the assay is very very simple it's
very
rapid it takes less than an hour to run
and it's fairly flexible it can be done
as a color metric in a color metric
version just in strip tubes or
regular tubes or it can be done as a
fluorescence assay say on a thermal
cycler
instrument and so um there's there was a
lot of buzz about this early on so we
started to do some some development in
that space
we looked at a number of different
primer sets actually five different sets
of primers
uh that we first did some testing with
and we also started with the
colorimetric enzyme mix
and we were looking at a couple of
different regions
that turned out to be the best in terms
of detecting sars curve 2.
and so that work actually went
relatively
quickly but what we noted right out of
the gate was that when we looked at
inactivated viral particles in water the
assay was far
far more sensitive than it was if we put
those same inactivated particles in
saliva
so this sort of presented the first
challenge and
we knew this wasn't just a challenge for
lamp
and i think many are very familiar with
this that
it's sort of known there is something in
saliva and it may be more than one thing
so there may be things in saliva that
are
inhibitory to these types of reactions
and not just lamp this has
been known for some time in the pcr
space as well
that there are some types of agents that
are present in saliva that just really
inhibit these types of reactions
and so we verified that with lamp as
well
so we basically made it our mission to
try to investigate many different types
of pre-treatments
on saliva that would allow us to
actually get the sensitivity out of the
assay that we desired
so after testing many many different
combinations
there were some actual beneficial
combinations that we identified
and in fact some of this is in a
preprint which is on met archive
uh and some of the data that you see on
the left of the slide or information you
see on the left of the slide is from
that preprint
and most of these combinations of things
involved both
diluting the saliva as well as heating
it
many different types of times of heating
temperatures of heating etc were tested
and then some of them also involved
additional reagents such as adding
things like protein sk
and some other reagents as well but
again as i said most of the beneficial
ones involve some type of dilution in
heating
that really seemed to be the key and
then eventually a stabilization buffer
for the rna as well
so our preliminary testing we were able
to get to 10 to the three particles per
microliter
very very quickly in this assay there's
about three microliters of input
just as a reference and you know
eventually with a little bit of testing
it didn't take us too long to get down
to where we were seeing
reasonably good results at about 10 to
the 2 particles per microliter or
roughly 100 particles per microliter of
input sample
with about three microliters of input
total and we were doing this in
initially as i said in strip tubes in
the colorimetric format
so these early results were promising um
and suggested that we might be able to
do this in higher throughput format
and that maybe we could target you know
something in the 10 particle per
microliter range
so that led us down an additional
component of this path where we tried to
take this into a high
throughput format and the conversion to
high throughput
was relatively straightforward we did
find that when we switched to 96 weld
plates
that the conditions that were optimal in
the strip tubes were not
as optimal in the 96 well plates and
vice versa
but different combinations of the up
front processing did
seem you know we were able to find
different versions for the different
formats that seem to get us to
pretty much the same level of
sensitivity and specificity between the
two
the the hype throughput and the low
throughput formats
the other nice thing about the 96 well
play format is not only could we do
color metric with a plate reader
we could also have a fluorescent readout
and actually for lamp
which isn't necessarily the focus of
this presentation it turned out the
fluorescent readouts were
better um again we had robust
sensitivity at about 10 to the two
particles or 100 particles per
microliter of input
but what you could see from this graph
is that once we got down to the 10 to
the one range
the results started to get highly
variable
they were also very dependent on the
amount of heating time
that was involved in the assay there's
about a 30 minute heat step
and you if you go a little bit short of
that you can get false negatives if you
go a little bit long from that you can
start to get false positives
so we kind of ran into this problem with
overlapping false positive false
negative range
and it was really really dependent and
and very sensitive to the timing
um which created uh limits for us
um you know we were trying to develop
this as a clinical grade assay
so that type of sensitivity
to a particular component of the assay
um
we knew was going to be problematic so
we kind of reached a
rough barrier of about 10 to 50
particles per microliter of input
and in that range we had this issue of
competing false positives false
negatives that we could not completely
eliminate
um so this this kind of brought us to
the conclusion
of where we were with this this original
uh foray into the assay development
realm where
we had an assay that looked very
promising on a lot of initial factors
you know lamp was very fast it's very
it's reasonably scalable it's very
flexible
it's incredibly easy to use and it's
very very cost effective
but there were problems we really could
not
get to consistent sensitivity
below 100 particles per microliter of
input roughly
give or take a little bit and once we
got down into the 10 particle per
microliter range
it the the sensitivity specificity uh
were fighting back and forth with each
other and we really couldn't get a
clean cut in that range
where we felt confident so our
conclusion was is this is probably very
well suited for a point of care device
uh something where you have higher viral
loads you're working with symptomatic
individuals
um you know and so that that might be a
great avenue for lamp
but after the two and a half months
worth of effort we could not
get this to something we considered to
be
uh sufficient for clinical grade testing
below ten to the
two particles per microliter of input
so around early may
we had a significant uh change in
direction
we had an initial contact with the
fluidine team
and basically found that they were
working on
a uh some kits that could potentially be
useful
for this application which you've
already heard a bit about
and we were interested given that we
couldn't quite reach what we
needed to get to with lamp we decided
this might be
a good avenue to try by mid-may
we were already beginning to test
samples so we had some contrived samples
that we had generated and we tested
those with fluid ion with some of their
different
rt preamplification conditions
and we were looking at viral n1n2 these
are the
cdc primers basically um that are
available from idt for n1 and n2 as well
as human rna sp is a
control for the host and right out of
the gate we noticed
very remarkable sensitivity we had no
trouble
immediately getting to ten to the one
particles per microliter of input
now this is a little bit more input it's
these are five microliter inputs for the
the
sta step but still this was
this was a fantastic result basically
given that we had just started
um so by mid to late may we were getting
reproducible results in our hands
down in that range and as you'll see we
actually got a little bit below that
range
uh for our eua and by early
june we were starting we were running
our testing our validation testing
for our eua and we had generated our all
of our data
and submitted our eua by mid-june
so david had mentioned a bit of this and
this is sort of the workflow our
workflow and it fairly closely matches
what you saw
in the previous slides so we take
we have the samples collected and those
go into a pre-treatment
step which is quite straightforward and
relatively simple to do
and those pre-treated samples then go
into the sta
for pre-amplification those are loaded
onto the
fluidim 192 by 24 ifc's which use either
the juno or rx controllers
to load the chip and then they go on to
a biomark where there
is machine readable data and in fact
software that we use from fluidim to
make the positive negative call
determinations
for the assay 5 microliters of input
is all we need for the assay at the sta
step
and was mentioned we actually run this
with the three
assays individually for the rtpcr on the
biomark
and we do those in quadruplicate so for
every sample that we put on to
an isc we have each assay in
quadruplicate
the the n1 the n2 in the rnap
so we get those four readouts and that's
part of our overall calling scheme in
terms of the
reproducibility for a clinical assay and
then we use four wells uh
on the sample side of the isc for
controls
so the validation studies started with
a limit of detection um we first had to
know where our
sensitivity range uh sort of ended and
what our specificity looked like as well
with negative samples and of course the
only way you can really do this is with
contri
samples so uh you had seen actually
a slide from david that had shown 6.25
as what they observed at fluid ion which
is exactly what we observed at washu
running the assay in our hands kind of
again speaking to the reproducibility
two different sites
using i think different control salivas
spiking in our own particles and
basically we hit pretty much exactly
the same limit of detection
i'd say there's only sort of some small
differences at the very low range and
i'll go into that in a minute but
this was actually very good confirmation
for us early early on
that this was a very reproducible assay
so our contrived samples used pooled
human saliva
as their base we added inactivated viral
particles in two-fold dilutions
the table that i'm showing here goes
from 100 down to 1.563 particles per
microliter of input
but we have actually tested higher and
lower than that
but this is this is the range where most
of the
useful information is generated
n1 or n2 are sufficient for a positive
call
and the particles as you see here we've
reported them in the table format
as particles per microliter of input
or in the bottom graph as particles per
reaction so
we know that some labs refer to their
their
limit of detection and sensitivity uh in
both ways so we've
for the purposes of this talk i've
reported them uh
in both formats so you can see that we
have 100
sensitivity at six and a quarter
particles per microliter
which translates to just about 31
particles per reaction
but if you look further down the list
you will see that
due to the n1 or n2 positivity
sufficient for calling
we were still seeing 80 sensitivity at
less than 10 particles per reaction
down at 1.5 uh particles per microliter
when we pulled the
in one and into information and the
eventual calls
we were seeing sensitivity at at uh
about 80 percent
um even that low so the assay was
incredibly sensitive for sure
uh the good news was there were no false
positives in the 20 negative samples
that were run as part of this chip
and i'll speak a bit more to that with
some of the other data
so before we get into the actual
validation
uh with the comparator samples from mp
swabs
there were a number of other factors
that we wanted to look at
so if we're going to run this as a
clinical test we have to be
assured that the samples can be
delivered
to us and still be viable for testing
so in order to do that in order to
determine that we had to do a number of
stability tests so the first test that
we did which is represented in the table
on the left and i
apologize numbers are a little small and
hard to read but
i'll summarize the result we did a room
temperature stability test we did
three different levels of particle spike
ins with multiple donors
similarly inactivated particles from 10
to the one to ten to the three particles
per microliter
and then we looked at room we held the
samples at room temperature
with no stabilization buffer of any kind
this is just saliva with particles in it
that's
it no other kind of buffer no
stabilization whatsoever basically just
sitting on
a laboratory bench from anywhere from 4
to 120 hours
and at about 120 hours we saw
just a small hint maybe a half a ct
shift from the zero time point control
the zero r time point control
so at room temperature in a closed vial
with no stabilization the samples were
virtually completely stable
for up to five days so this was good
news this at least meant that things
could be collected
the night before two days before maybe
even three days before obviously you
don't want to go too far beyond that
and have a relative a relevant result
because lots of things can happen in
that period of time
in terms of the individual but uh at
least we knew the stamp
samples were quite stable at that time
frame
but not every sample is going to
sit at room temperature if samples have
to be transported
in st louis or houston or miami in july
there's every uh chance that those
samples might be subjected to
temperatures much higher than room
temperature
so we then did an environmental
stability test so we used room
temperature as our
control since we had already done a very
extensive test
and what you see in the graph on the
right is the results for the 100
particle
per microliter 10 to the 2 of
of inactivated particles per microliter
input sample
so at room temperature rt for 100
particles you can see
that basically there was no difference
between zero time point
and going all the way out to 96 hours so
basically replicating the result we had
had before
room temperature these samples are
completely stable up to at least five
days
96 hours was just four days for this
test but
clearly it replicated the original
results so that was great
you can see that chilling them at least
not freezing them but keeping them at
cool temperatures also is perfectly fine
four degrees celsius 39 degrees
fahrenheit uh
100 particles was unchanged
for four days 35 degrees we started to
see a bit of movement so 35 degrees
celsius are 95 degrees fahrenheit
basically a hot day outside
in some of the southern states you do
start to see
a bit of decline as especially as you
get out to the 72 and 96 hour time
points
and again this is 100 particles per
microliter
at 10 particles per microliter we even
started to lose a couple of the samples
at 72 to 96 hours at 95 degrees but
basically up to 48 hours the samples
were quite stable
where we really see a decline is at 54
degrees celsius or 129 degrees
fahrenheit so this is a sample being
left in a hot car
on a sunny day so the uh
at up to eight hours interestingly the
samples were quite stable
but once we got from eight hours to 24
and all of those
points from 24 hours out to 96 are
collected at what we called 32
it's actually 999 there was no read on
the fluidim instrument there was no
signal
um we just set it at 32 so that we would
be able to graph it
we use that internally as sort of a
marker of the uh
of no signal coming from the the uh
biomark instrument
and so this basically though told us
that yes you could have high
temperatures for a short period of time
but once you got past that short period
of time these samples would be
compromised
okay so the samples are fairly stable
for a good period of time even up to
fairly warm conditions as long as you
don't get
uh very warm hot like i said is a
the equivalent of being inside of a
locked hot car
for more than eight hours but that that
gives us good
confidence that these samples will be
quite stable for transport
assuming you don't have extreme
conditions for very long periods of time
however and we've we've communicated
with other labs who've seen this as well
but the particles do not tolerate all
that well is freeze thaw
so interestingly enough when you
uh we basically had noticed that some of
our positive controls seem to have
increased cts
over time and we eventually traced that
back to the particle aliquots that it
had multiple freeze thaws
so this concerned us and we decided well
we better do a test
for the particle stability that we're
using for our controls
um and at the same time this also tells
us that if we get real samples
you probably don't want to be
freestyling those samples very
often that that could be problematic so
if you're going to aliquot something out
and use it it's probably good to have a
couple of aliquots so that if you want
to go back to a sample
even if it's a real world sample you you
need to be aware
of this that this is definitely an issue
um
and not so much with the assay but with
the particles themselves
so um we performed the stability study
and what we noticed was
each and every freeze thaw seemed to
increase the cts
by three freeze thaws we were losing our
low level control on the chip which is
25 particles per microliter
by the time we got to four freeze thaws
and above we started to lose our high
level controls which is a thousand
so even with real world samples we've
seen this that this freeze thaw
cycles are not good for these types of
samples so
this at least establishes that baseline
we know that for our controls we're
going to use fresh aliquots and we
really try to keep our
real world samples at less than two
freeze thaws because you could lose
sensitivity as a result
and again not due to the assay itself
due to the nature of these viral
particles
okay once we completed all of that we
finally got to the point
of completing our full on sensitivity
specificity comparing to
np swab data so we had a number of
samples collected here
under a couple of different protocols at
washington university
where we had saliva that was collected
with matched np swaps
the np suaves were run through eua
approved
testing and the saliva for
the samples that were in our validation
study
all but three of those samples the
saliva was collected within 24 hours of
the np swabs
and in fact i think only us a number few
of those were within 24 hours most of
those were collected within an hour
so they are you know for the vast
majority of these they are true
matched saliva nt collections
and uh just a couple that where the uh
saliva was
collected a few days after the np swap
and within this test set we had perfect
concordance we saw 34
we had 34 positives and 34 negatives as
david had mentioned
we saw that 100 sensitivity
and 100 specificity all the positives
matched all the negatives matched
the mean cts for n1 generally run around
16 and a half
and these patients remember these are
symptomatic patients
um and n2 seems to average around 18.
it's it's been known for some time and
two seems to be
a little less sensitive in terms of the
cts at which it's detected
than in one with these uh cdc primers
and rnasp mean which is the basically
just your human endogenous controls
it comes in at about 14. so
this was great and what i can tell you
is that we have completed
numerous replications of this for our
internal cap clear validation as well
and in processing basically 272 samples
for our cap clia
i think we maybe have seen two false
negatives on
very very low end positive samples
uh that had actually undergone multiple
freeze thaws otherwise we've had
virtually perfect concordance
so the wash you scale up uh looks
something like this
so the what i put out is the simple
workflow
is fine if you're doing a few hundred
samples a day
it is our intent to eventually get this
up to in relatively short time frame up
to 10 000 samples a week
that's our goal in about the next five
to six weeks
and our eventual target is about 50 000
samples per week within our laboratory
so the samples are collected into 2d
barcoded tubes
which allows us to scan those at our
intake and accessioning
and we are doing the first
three pieces of what you see up here in
a bsl two plus environment
so the we take 48 tubes per rack
into a capital machine which can decap
the tubes
the d-cap tubes are then plated onto 96
well plates
with an eppendorf 5070
series robot for pre-treatment the tubes
are recapped
and those are stored so that we can go
back to those remember this is a
clinical
laboratory process so we have to be able
to go back to these at least the
positives for some period of time
we use an ep96 then to do a plate to
play transfer after we have
applied the pre-treatment protocol
to get these to the sda plate and then
basically everything from there on out
is the standard fluidity workflow
so this is basically how we're working
to bring this up to very high throughput
so in summary um we have been able to
develop a saliva based test with in my
mind
very reasonable volume requirements um
500 microliters is our target volume but
we can do this with as little as 50
microliters of input
saliva is highly inconsistent from
subject to subject even in healthy
volunteers
um so you know it's it's the amount that
you get the consistency
uh varies quite a bit and so the assay
has to be very robust for that
and so far all of the work that we've
done has shown that
that all of those uh issues can be
addressed
and that we are able to get down to even
very very small volumes of input again
we only need five microliters
of the mixture at the end for the sda
reaction in the fluid ion assay so
this is this is a very very reasonable
volume requirement
for the sample elderly people and some
other folks can actually have difficulty
producing a large amount of saliva
especially those who are sick so we
think this is actually very reasonable
assay scaling with robotics our initial
target as i mentioned is 10 000 per week
with our eventual target of about 50 000
per week
uh we're very happy with our limit of
detection and stability
uh we think that these samples will
transport quite well
even not necessarily being on ice
especially if they're local
if they have to transport a long way at
least being on ice would probably be a
good idea to keep them from any high
temperatures but
even if they reach room temperature that
should not be a problem for extended
periods of time
sensitivity and specificity were again
great hundreds of negatives have now
been tested
without any false positives we don't
actually know what our
specificity is yet because we
haven't run enough samples to get a
false negative with this current version
of the kit
um to be able to call it but we do know
that we're well
we're below one percent we know that
because we've already run hundreds
um without hitting a false positive
we we might have had one in a very
recent run but
like i said we'll be well below one
percent uh
with the specificity um the only false
negatives we've had to this point
uh were actually samples that were
collected many days apart from the np
swab so they're probably not even really
false negatives they're probably cases
where the infection has resolved over
that lengthy period of time
another big win for this is as david has
mentioned there is no requirement for
rna extraction
this really helps with supply chain
issues speed and cost
and we went from basically nothing to
the data that we needed for our eua
submission in about a four to five week
window
so and that was with us you know
basically doing initial testing to
ensure that our pre-treatment steps were
working well with the
the um advanta dx workflow so
um with that in mind
a few acknowledgements credit where
credit is due
as david had mentioned jeff melbrandt is
our chair of the department of genetics
and my boss
he's the also the executive director of
the mcdonald genome institute
and another a number of folks rob from
rob metra's lab and willie buckster's
lab we're very instrumental in a lot of
the
upfront lamp work that we did to
find these different pre-treatment
protocols that really enabled samples
for
uh downstream processing our technology
development group at mgi
under bob fulton uh katrina franek and
lisa cook have done a tremendous job
and then just uh i cannot say enough
about
chris sawyer lauren bertia and shelio
laughlin so
chris and lauren developed and did all
of the assay testing
to get and everything all the data that
she saw generated here today
uh and shelly basically wrote almost our
entire ua
so uh um and you know they're both in
mike and lucinda's lines here at the mgi
and of course the fluidized team
so on that note i will stop and if there
are questions i believe there will be
somebody available to answer questions
from the talk
thank you dr king and professor head for
your informative presentation
we will now start the q a portion of the
webinar
i would like to introduce dr king back
and shelly o'loughlin who will be
answering questions on behalf
of professor head if you have a question
you'd like to ask
please do so now just click on the ask a
question box
located on the far left of your screen
now
let's get started our first question is
which are the advantages of using saliva
versus nasopharyngeal swabs
two perhaps i'll answer that question
this is david king and
um i think from our perspective uh
saliva
is a much easier to use um
[Music]
sample matrix uh in cla on the
collection
side there's one doesn't need any ppe
that
requires salt collection um
compliance is going to be much higher um
than using nasal pharyngeal swabs
especially either self-administered
nasopharyngeal swabs or
um healthcare worker nasa uh
nasopharyngeal swabs um there's also
the issue of supply chain so as you
heard throughout this presentation we
have worked
to eliminate extraction as part of this
effort and the
reduction in the amount of reagents used
and the
number of reagents used and the control
we have
over our entire supply chain eliminates
extraction based supply chain issues
so those are sort of the main main areas
main advantages of using cyber venezuela
and dr king it looks like we have
another one for you which is the maximum
throughput achievable
and what do you need to achieve it sure
so
maximum put achievable with the workflow
that
rich and i both have described is
up to 6000 samples per day and that's a
24-hour day
uh seven days a week it can be achieved
with one of our biomark hd
systems one controller either a juno or
an lx controller
and a couple of thermal a 964 plate
thermal cyclos
it's very simple workflow and it's
very very flexible
and now is your test a multiplex test
um yes so we simultaneously detect
well it depends let me explain what that
means we simultaneously detect three
targets
n1 n2 and rnap
the sample is loaded only once into the
microfluidic chip
but the targets are amplified in
separate compartments of
the chip so there's separate separate
reactions
so uh thanks to the capability of
technology
we use just a few nanoliters per
reaction and perform a large amount of
reactions in parallel
so we're able to save um really
expensive
uh enzymatic material while providing a
huge throughput
in terms of data points per processing
run
so we don't actually have to multiplex
in a single chamber
so so it is strictly not a multiplex
test
it's actually just the same as running
each of the assays in an individual well
and so it actually affords a lot of
opportunity and
reduction of issues associated with
complex multiplex tests
now dr king i do have a two-part
question for you
compared to the lamp method which no rna
extraction step is required
are the five ul pre-treated samples
subject to rna extraction to obtain the
quality rna first
then loaded for this advanta dx assay
and without high quality rna do you
still expect to get accurate results
okay so that's an interesting question
um
no the um
there is no extraction um as part of the
workflow that you heard today
for the advanta product uh it starts
with saliva
and goes through um a rt
pcr preamp step without any extraction
so we start with saliva as the sample
matrix um there is the saliva can
slider can be can have quite degraded
rna
so uh doesn't have to work with
perfectly
pure you know pristine high quality rna
i've been number rna
so we uh without so to answer the second
part of the question
um we don't uh quant we don't
screen samples or do anything associated
with
validation of the samples for the
testing or use of this product
in terms of high quality rna so it works
on
on any type of saliva
now shelly we do have a question for you
how many patient samples can you run per
batch
um we run 192 and the ifc chip we do add
um
four controls per set of 96 so for just
the
patient samples themselves it'll be 184.
we want to thank our audience we are
getting so many great questions today so
let's look
for another one
all right um let's go here
uh so dr king is the input into the
reaction saliva that is undiluted
and how much of original saliva is used
per reaction to get the lowest range of
detection
the protocol uses uh 12 and a half or a
minimum of
12 and a half microliters of saliva um
there is no dilution
uh while we do it we do dilute it one to
one with
um pbs as part of the protocol but
there's no
necessarily solution up front so that's
the i think that's the
uh answer to that that question
and is the collection just plain saliva
or do you have to buffer in the tube
i know it's plain saliva next one
and now what may be in saliva that
inhibits the enzyme reaction
uh there are a variety of different
inhibitors
the the eua data that we propose
has showed just works with neat saliva
we are
um we believe that um from literature
studies in
our field and other fields that
inhibition is not going to be a
substantial issue for the reaction that
we've described
for the workflow we've described
we hear that tests currently require
repetition to get an expected positive
result
why is that happening and how do we
reduce the number of false negatives
but also um
but also false negatives i apologize
that may be a mistake on the question
so how do we reduce the number of false
negatives
uh we so so that's a general statement
about
testing in general rather than the
advanta uh product that we've just
described in any in the work that we've
described both
here and at washu we've not seen any um
[Music]
issues associated with false negatives
um
so we have i should note that
we as part of the
protocol actually do four assay
replicates
um for each four individual replicates
of each sample
our microfluidic chip affords so when we
run in 192 samples as you just heard
surely say
oh each sample is is actually processed
in
quadruplicate and uh we use that
information to
um really assist in the reduction of
uh any types of false positive false
negatives
now dr king what is the estimated cost
per test
i'm going to have to leave that that
question up to our commercial team
if you interested in following up with
with uh with us and about that
um uh please reach out to uh
fluidign uh that depends on a variety of
different
issues in terms of volume and scale of
the of the uh
particular workflow that you're
anticipating using so i strongly
encourage you to reach out and discuss
that very topic with us
great now let me just say let me i will
hang on i will say
that uh we are very cost competitive as
you heard us describe the technology
uh uh in terms of using minimize
minimizing the amount of
reagents that are used and minimizing
the volumes that are used
we are extraordinarily cost competitive
now shelley do you have any data on
concordance with the np swabs for
asymptomatic patients
no we do not yet um we have only had
clinical patients that have been um in
the hospital that we have
for clinical studies um we would like to
start
doing that soon so
and shelly would it be possible in the
future to develop the kit to study
co-pathogens
i believe so david maybe i should
uh the answer is the answer is obviously
yes um
as i mentioned we have a plenty of space
on
our microfluidic chip so we can run
many essays on top of just uh
n1 n2 and rnhp for let's say influenza a
b
rhinovirus a variety of other pathogens
we're working with customers constantly
to imagine solutions in that space and
deliver solutions in that space
okay
now dr king i have one for you is heat
inactivation at 90 degrees celsius and
10 minutes as specified in the
instructions for you sufficient
and have you tested this on the the live
virus
uh i believe that question might be best
coming from
for push from shelley but i think the
answer is yes
it is certainly sufficient um there's
lots of publications um
demonstrating that that's the case i
think there's a cdc guideline for that
showing that that's the uh
requiring that for in of activation um
testing it on live virus uh would be the
case that uh
uh shelley that's really a question for
shelly it's part of her concordance
study
for um positives that she ran using the
essay really do you want to
maybe address this sure yes we had um we
worked in collaboration with another lab
here at washu
and um they did do they did
test it on my virus and said the 90
degrees was great at
killing at inactivating it so they had
previously we had previously used 56
degrees at 30 minutes
but we found this 90 degree at 10
minutes worked even better
great so let's see if we have if we have
time for maybe one more question
okay looks like we've got one more
what is the age profile of the clinical
patients used in the validation
we did not have access to that
information
i think those studies had to be blinded
so yeah
we didn't have any of that information
yeah for the
patients
our intended use statement um in the
eua is in parallel is equivalent to what
what shoe has does not have an age
element to it so we did not then thus
study
um cohorts of patients
in different age categories it
works across all uh age groups
and looks like that was going to be our
last question we want to thank you both
for your time today
and your important research before we go
i'd like to thank the audience for
joining us today and for their
interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period
will be addressed by the seekers via the
contact information that you provided at
the time of the registration
please join the meeting room at 9 30 and
visit our covit 19 diagnostics booth
which is the second row on the right you
can find cost information and any other
questions that you may have can be
answered there
this webcast can be viewed on demand
through july of 2021
until next time goodbye